[Music]
we love all the Disney Princesses but
some are just more powerful than others
stay tuned to find out which princess is
way more powerful than Elsa are you new
around here don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up and subscribe to
the things for more great content like
this now on to who is the most powerful
Disney Princess I can handle this Aurora
what comes to mind when Aurora is
mentioned sleep of course which is the
perfect description of this beauty
seeing how she's the most boring
princess in the Disney franchise even
reimagined from the viewpoint of
Maleficent it makes you wonder was there
really no discussion on how to make her
more appealing to young girls she's
beautiful and she sleeps we can relate
but we certainly aren't princesses might
be add that she has the least amount of
lines than any other Princess Aurora is
definitely the least powerful and the
least interesting she is respected only
for being one of the first Disney
Princesses her value is determined by
those around her and nothing is her
choice with fairies then the witch and
the prince half of her lines involved
singing for this man
what is there to admire maybe the fact
that she can look good while sleeping
Snow White while Snow White has a little
more depth in Aurora her being powerful
is still in question respected as the
first Disney Princess Snow White was not
expected to have such a large impact
maybe we can give her kudos for that
but Snow White's story is a little
different she's innocent and loyal which
aren't bad qualities she runs away after
a mirror tells her she's more beautiful
than the Queen and warns her of her
forthcoming death which is
understandable no one's ready to die she
runs to a house with seven dwarfs and
earns her keep as a trophy wife making
sure the house is as clean as can be the
Prince saves her in the end there's a
trend here as tired as the storyline is
none of the other princesses would exist
without her Cinderella the girl lives as
a servant in her dad's house forced to
do all the hard labor and appease her
stepmother and sisters we feel for
Cinderella there's a whole world right
outside her door and she doesn't even
realize it until she meets a prince
she's pretty poor and far removed from
everything
this is her downfall but you can't deny
the message sent from all the Cinderella
adaptations have courage and be kind a
simple message that doesn't hurt to
teach little kids but Cinderella's happy
ending depended on fate not action she
was willing to continue her life of
servitude another Prince another happy
ending how many movies need this
reiteration the only reason her life
changed was because her rich Prince
thought she was pretty had she not met
him she wouldn't have even made this
list Ariel can we contribute the
majority of Ariel's impulsive decisions
to her being young she's 16
rebellious creative and beautiful a
breath of fresh air for Disney
princesses she stands up for herself
making her voice heard to her father
daddy they're not barbarians her voice
being the most beautiful trait and what
does she do sacrifice her voice for legs
to live on land why does she do it cuz
she saw a cute boy and wanted to pursue
him she is a teenager but come on her
traits are admire Belen the beginning
but as the film progresses we see this
being attributed to her just being boy
crazy literally all of her actions
revolve around getting to know him Ariel
can be a toss-up she's headstrong and
craves independence but let's point out
that she would rather be silenced in
order to win Eric's attention rapunzel
Rapunzel is one of the most famous tales
ever told a woman is trapped in a castle
with exceptionally long hair but she
doesn't think to use to escape but
offers it to a prince who then uses her
hair to climb up and save her that was
the old version which is why Rapunzel is
number 11 however in Disney's adaptation
tangled Rapunzel is a girl who is just
waiting for the day she can escape but
no time has been wasted while locked in
the tower she studies books and learns
how to fight using her hair we can't
forget the iconic frying pan scene in
the end she is saved by a prince but her
happily ever after involves her seeing
the world the girl knows her worth the
prince is simply in addition to her
already found happiness jasmine there is
no doubt about it
jasmine is a romantic there's nothing
wrong with wanting love but jasmine will
not be the product of an arranged
marriage
similar to Ariel Jasmine stands up for
herself to her father and speaks up for
what she believes in
is wrong quick to call a man out jasmine
does not care what any man has to offer
the movie isn't even about her and she's
still extremely progressive for a Disney
princess in the words of Jasmine I am
NOT a prize to be won could a more
powerful message exist for young girls
who love Disney Princesses Jasmine knows
what she brings to the table she knows
she is desired by many men and has the
impact to change laws
she's a very solid princess with strong
values what more could you ask for Belle
Belle is one of the first princesses in
the Disney franchise to be seen as smart
and free thinking this taught young
girls that it's okay to love learning
and think for yourself
I want much more than this provincial
life she says in the film in her village
they don't fancy her love of books she
is the only woman with an inch of
intelligence and self-awareness the girl
has ambition finding marriage and
Families subpart to whatever else life
can offer magic he asked me to marry did
we forget to mention her selflessness
she volunteers as a prisoner in order to
Creeper father then she meets the beast
who was brewed and selfish she changes
the Beast into a caring man that she
eventually Falls for and marries the way
she values creativity and intelligence
makes her a perfect role model
Pocahontas while being a film that
definitely glorified colonialism the
film did give us Pocahontas
she's the first American Disney Princess
and it's one of the most underrated can
we focus on her love for the environment
and the animals that lived in it
Pocahontas chose her own fate leaving
John Smith behind she is a princess who
is always looking for the greater good
Pocahontas makes the men and elders in
her community listen to her sending the
message that women can have opinions
she's no damsel in distress instead
she's saving John Smith's life which is
a first for Disney Princesses Pocahontas
instills feminism in girls at an early
age which is always something to get
behind in the end we also see that
destiny is much bigger than romance
Merida arranged marriage is nothing new
especially in the case of Merida she's a
princess being forced to marry by her
parents Merida acknowledges the
establishment her parents want her to
marry into she should be subservient
but Merida is challenging everything
from gender norms to
femininity is perceived in her country
she dresses in tomboy fashion which
really gets her parents shook you can
also count on Merida to be vocal about
women coming in all shapes and sizes
making you reconsider your original
perception of what it means to be a girl
we love a good body positivity princess
brave Sims the message of being true to
yourself which is always key Merida is
adventurous and a true individual she
doesn't care for anything her Queen
Mother tries to set her up for whether
it be romance squirrel tea or a
respectability tiana princess tiana is
independent what other disney princess
do you know that owns a business from
the beginning we see her professing her
dreams of owning her own restaurant her
aim in life is to be successful she is a
true go-getter who meets a frog and
falls in love who wouldn't fall in love
with a girl like Tiana an independent
business owner taking life as it comes
when it comes to being saved this is not
the narrative form is Tiana she doesn't
become a princess until the end but she
is all the while deserving she sends the
message to young viewers that you have
to fight for what you want and it's
going to take a lot to get there The
Princess and the Frog also features a
soundtrack with inspiring songs about
zeona
getting ready to reach her dreams what
more could you ask for
Esmerelda no princess touches on
discrimination quite like Esmeralda
she's a gypsy who wants to fix in
justices like poverty and
marginalization she has the attention of
three men Quasimodo
Rollo and captain Phoebus she sends the
message that she is the master of her
own body and she decides what she wants
to do with it she has the power to
choose who she wants to be with which
isn't that revolutionary but she does
choose the right guy Phoebus is perfect
for her because she does not try to
change her as Narada is a free-thinking
woman ready to fight for what is right
you speak of justice yet you are cruel
to those most in need of your help it's
important to show young viewers to
choose a partner who doesn't try to
change them even if the other guys have
a lot of power
mogera one of the most underrated
princesses in the Disney franchise is
mogera maybe it's because of her
attitude but do all princesses have to
be nice just because you aren't super
nice but doesn't make your opinions or
impact any less powerful the Mean Girls
are always depicted as the villain
but some of them are just logical she
smashes the concept of smiling because
it'll make you more approachable with
cold stares we don't have to smile all
the time women are not robots and nobody
proves this more than mogera with her
sarcasm and witty remarks his translates
in her love life as well
she's cynical and intelligent you know
how men are she says in the film her
modern feminist thinking was way before
its time
Elsa could we have a Disney Princess
list and not include Elsa the Ice Queen
deserves many praises for not only not
needing a prince but looking out for her
sister as well frozen is one of the few
Disney movies that doesn't include a
protagonist getting married the bond
between Elsa and Anna is the true love
story here after their parents death and
after Elsa separates herself to protect
her sister from her powers they make
their way back to each other is Elsa
identify as a feminist the movie doesn't
take a stance but her need to place
family and independence over everything
else prove that she holds values that
register with the movement more so than
some of her earlier mentioned comrades
you can't marry a man you just met and
have you heard let it go
the movies theme song will have you
singing along with the rest of the world
Mulan Mulan is such a classic tale of
women being able to do whatever men can
do and most of the time women do it a
lot better while her family is focused
on her honoring their name by marriage
Mulan has other things on her mind she
saves all of China for crying out loud
she challenges everything that comes her
way including gender roles this was a
very hard thing for her to do
considering her traditional background
Mulan embodies recognizing her strength
and not counting herself out just
because she is a girl it's amazing how
she saved the lives of men who would not
have done the same for her Mulan is a
representation of strong women ones who
are not afraid of a challenge she's also
one of the first princesses to make
being empowered the norm she lets it be
known that the princess life is not for
her switching out the dress for armor
Moana ok here are South's
we know Moana is not technically a
princess seeing how her father is a
chief but she is the most empowered
leading lady in a dizzy film not
focusing on someone to save her but what
it saves herself she defies all odds
stacked up against her to do
which he sees is bright she is
uncomfortable on her journey at all
times but she's persistent meeting Maui
along the way she's able to teach him
about teamwork and the importance of
seeing your vision through me her mantra
to go where no one has gone before
where no one has dared to go so she can
save her village from destruction and be
a great leader that sounds powerful to
us that's it for who is the most
powerful Disney Princess were you
surprised by the ranking of the
princesses on the list let us know in
the comments thanks for watching
[Music]